[Music]
[Applause]
let's uh bring on the uh former bengal
quarterback heisman trophy winner here
in town at usc uh raider quarterback
arizona cardinal quarterback and a guy
who's been a great contributor to this
program let's uh bring him on
carson palmer is
he's in the building to see you boys
got a pair of
here got a pair of fresh
fresh shoes on there fresh j's yeah some
fresh j's i've been saving these for
your show they look good in person they
look good thank you we saw mark sanchez
uh he came in uh yesterday and he had
his nikes and uh he had the the swoosh
that was usc colors
yeah hand fresh was on as well he did
admit you were faster than him
barely was yeah was oh you're probably
still faster than him i'm gonna guess he
might have had bigger hands than you i
doubt that uh
do you i don't know do you have a ruler
he had pause maybe he had some pause
there see you didn't just shake carson's
hand those his hands are gigantic you
have big hands mark's saying buzz good
size okay check the combine here because
i might go sanchez paulie i have from
the combine the 10th highest best hand
size of all time is uh mark sanchez at
10.5 inches yeah i'm not in the top i
have you at
10.25 but i don't know if that's
official
[Applause]
but check the 40 times that's no he did
admit i mean that's the one thing
sanchez has on you is he has bigger
hands that's it i'll take speed over
hand size
oh okay yeah does hand slice matter
it does um
especially when you play on the east
coast
in the wind in the rain
it just helps you get a little bit
better grip and and you just don't see
that many guys in the league right now
with i don't know what the the top ten
is ten something inches but you don't
see many guys in the eights and nines it
just gets more and more difficult with
the wind to spin it
and aaron rodgers has big hands he's
talked about that he liked the football
inflated a little bit more and then you
have the story with kenny pickett we're
like uh oh my god he doesn't want to do
he didn't want to get his hands measured
like that's that that's
i guess she puts his hands in his
pockets
at the combine like i don't want to have
you measure my hands like my my stock is
going to drop it does i mean that
there's so many coaches there's so many
organizations that are looking at that
number and that's an extremely important
statistic for those guys
why didn't you run more
well
i did run a bit um and then i blew my
knee out and everything changed after
that i lost a little bit of speed it
took me a couple years that's what blows
me away about joe burrow right now is he
blew his knee out last year mid-season
and you don't see any ramifications from
that injury you don't see him tentative
you don't see him you know a lot of
times you you'll have an issue stepping
into throws transferring your weight
turning on that front leg and that knee
spinning and rotating you're not seeing
at all with joe i felt it for at least a
couple years and it took me a couple
years to really feel 100 with joe right
now he looks 100 he looks he looks like
he did at lsu or before the knee injury
with cincinnati
paulie uh give carson the poll question
okay which quarterback would you bet on
you got a bet on who would have the most
super bowl appearances in the next
decade going forward super bowl
appearances joe burrow josh allen justin
herbert patrick mahomes
i think i like what's going on in
buffalo i i like the combination of
ownership gm coaching staff and
quarterback with with josh allen i think
the the ceiling is extremely high not
that it's not high with with burro i
think he's got an extremely high ceiling
but when you combine
the ownership group coaching staff and
the division you've got miami still
trying to figure it out for josh allen
uh you've got new england who is still
new england but they don't have tom
brady um who else am i missing in the
afc east
the jets
you got the jets i mean i i like that
setup for josh to get in the playoffs
and i think we'll see him in at least
one super bowl if not more coming up see
i said mahomes just because you still
have tyree kill and travis kelsey
nobody has that for a couple years until
tyreek hill has to get paid and tell
travis kelsey's next deal up um they've
got some issues they're paying patrick
um you know
they're paying him a much different
salary than than joe burrows getting
right now so joe burrows got him he's
got that going for himself salary cap
wise but i just think
josh allen's ceiling is only going to
get higher we're going to see him
continue to get better and we haven't
seen the best of them yet and it's been
really good so far but it feels like
that window of opportunity is about five
years that that you get that rookie
contract with your quarterback because
that's how seattle won with russ once
you start paying these guys it's really
hard to pay everybody else
the bengals are in really good shape
right now justin herbert with the
chargers they're in really good shape
right now but then that's going to
change when those guys get paid 50
million dollars a year
you know i think the most interesting
thing after the super bowl whether the
bengals win or not is the bengals are
going into next season with 58 or 59
million dollars in cap space
they've got joe burrow who is watching
what they do when you look at this
bengals roster
pre this you know before the season
started this was not a super bowl roster
there was not many people saying
oh man look how deep the bengals are
look how talented they are
nobody saw this coming joe burrows
watching how the organization
goes forward after this season he wants
to know what they're going to do with
that 60 million dollars in cap space his
deal's up is in two years he can he can
sign a big extension in two years and he
is really really watching are the
bengals going to do what they did in the
past which is just kind of sit around
and wait in the draft and hope somebody
falls to him are they going to make a
little bit of a splash and free agency
this is a chance where they can rebuild
that offensive line get another good
swing tackle get another pass restaurant
on defense they've got a lot of cap
space going in next year and nobody
is more curious what they're going to do
with it than joe
yeah and you went through this because
the bengals are a cheap organization or
they have been and you have this
opportunity and you're right if i'm joe
burrow like let's let's take advantage
of this opportunity plus i'm going to
guess free agents are going to want to
play
for a team that's led by joe burrow
receivers offensive lineman you know
guys want to get to the super bowl and
joe looks like he's got that magic he's
got the charisma he's now done it he's
gotten here um
and the bengals in the past haven't
pulled out the checkbook and written big
checks and and signed it you know you
got chandler jones who's a great pass
rusher that's a free agent um there's
some there's some there's some game
changers devonta
devonte adams is another weapon
you know if i'm joe i'm looking at um
you know brandon sherf who's in
washington who was a top 10 pick who's
been a great guard and all pro he's a
free agent uh there's some tackles that
are free so there's enough pieces to
continue to build on this current roster
that got to a super bowl that nobody
thought was going to get to get them to
a super bowl so joe's watching that and
and we're all watching as bengal fans we
want to see them make some moves in free
agency not you know sit around on the
draft and hope somebody follows them get
aggressive and continue to build on what
they've got started here we're talking
to carson palmer uh joining us on behalf
of level select cbd makes you use the
promo code carson 40. growing up in
cincinnati and i tell this story often
on the show if you say you're from
cincinnati people go oh the bungles like
that would be the first thing that they
would say as the quarterback for
cincinnati when you guys weren't playing
well what is that feeling like every
single day
when you're walking around or your wife
will hear something uh just being the
quarterback for a team that you know
people around the league would laugh at
it's frustrating and and we heard joe
talk about it early he got tired of the
narrative of the same old bengals he's
talked about
as soon as they beat uh the beat the
raiders in the playoffs he started
talking about changing the narrative and
we're we're we're a different team we're
a different organization than we were in
the past you know being in cincinnati um
the fan base there is so passionate and
loved you didn't hear that in cincy as
much as when you would travel or you'd
go uh to california or you go to these
different places and somebody go oh you
play for the bungles it's not that it's
not so much the case in cincinnati
there's so much passion that's why this
super bowl is so excited this this fan
base deserves this they've been waiting
30 something years for this they've
never won a lombardi trophy so
it's an exciting time to be in
cincinnati it's an exciting time to be a
bengal and i mean for joe to be here in
year two this is the beginning of a tom
brady like legacy you know tom got in
early won his first one early and then
continued to stack trophies after that
joe's in that same category of can he
continue to build after this game can he
win multiple super bowls he's not
wanting to win one joe's got a different
mindset he's a different individual he's
seeing multiple championships and this
is the start of him
what's going on with kyler murray in the
cardinals that he now scrubbed his
social media of anything that's related
to the arizona cardinals i i think it
looks like a contract play to me i mean
i obviously he's he's you know upset uh
displeased with his current negotiation
between his agent and the organization
um he just wants to up this he wants to
get a head start and get that like josh
allen got in buffalo he wants a year he
wants it today he didn't want to wait an
extra year and um say what you want how
how different guys go about getting that
next contract it certainly to me looks
like a contract move and he's trying to
leverage himself and position himself
for a contract this upcoming season
have we seen the best of kyler murray
we have at times um
you know that
i don't know what the ceiling is
for a quarterback who plays that way
that style and his strengths and
weaknesses
well you're seeing his weaknesses in the
last couple games teams are not letting
him outside the pocket he is not six
seven he is not six two he's not really
six feet tall so what they're doing is
keeping him in the pocket unfortunately
from a contractual situation for kyler
this that was his chance the playoffs
were his chance against the rams
to get a new contract this year
unfortunately he did not play well they
did not play well he lost a ton of
leverage and when you when you're a
player in the league and your contract
is coming up or you have a chance to
sign a new contract and you have
leverage you've got to take advantage of
it he did not take advantage of the
situation he all the leverage was on his
side all he had to do was play well they
could still have lost the rams but he
had to play well he lost all the
leverage he had going into it and it's
it's unfortunate because you don't get
it very often when you're a player and
you're coming up on a deal
that leverage is massive and and the
weight that that carries throughout the
organization is massive and when it's on
your side you got to take advantage of
it he lost a lot of leverage in that
playoff game same with baker mayfield he
lost all of his leverage this year by
being banged up and i think that's why
he kept trying to play is i want to get
some leverage here and it only made it
worse same deal and both organizations
are in the same spot they've got to pay
baker and they've got to pay kyler both
of those organizations you cannot
regardless of how poorly baker played or
how how bad that playoff game went for
kyler you got to pay him you took him
number one you're not going to go back
to the drawing board and start all over
and try to find the next guy they've got
to pay him both of those guys lost some
money and left some money on the table
with their performance this year brady
mentioned on his podcast that never say
never after so he's only been home for
six days now all of a sudden he's
reconsidering like what is it like when
you retired that first month you're at
home
what's it like
it was awesome i wasn't at home we
traveled
we went up to lake tahoe i played a i
did a lot of things i've been wanting to
do i love to hunt and fish and hunting
and fishing season for the most part is
during football season so as soon as i
didn't have a job playing football i did
a lot of the things with my family with
some buddies that i wanted to do that i
wasn't able to do for you know 25 years
of playing football so i think you know
brady is a habitual creature a creature
of habit he likes to do the same thing
over and over and over again now that
that's not there and he's just gotten a
very short taste of it i think there's a
thought in his head like you know i
could win eight
maybe i could win eight let's see what
happens with chris godwin they're gonna
resign chris godwin and in
in tampa are they gonna re-sign ryan
jensen the center in tampa maybe he's
waiting to sit back and see what happens
he's getting a little bored he's used to
starting you know whatever point in the
offseason he starts training again and
doing his flexibility then don't
announce you're retiring if you're still
not fully retired it's hard to give it
up it's hard when you've been doing it
for 20 something years and at that level
i mean he could those numbers he could
easily be the mvp this year it's hard to
retire on top too it's hard to retire
it's really hard to retire on top i at
the end was done my body was done i was
beat up i physically knew he's walking
off the field probably feeling pretty
good yeah you know a little banged up a
little beat up from playing a long
season but now that his body's recovered
he's starting to you know he's starting
to feel a little bit better i i wouldn't
be surprised if we saw him come back
how did the rams win this game
up front defensively up front the
weakest part of the bengals is the
offensive line we i mean they sacked
they sucked joe burrow nine times when
you think about getting sacked nine
times in a game it's demoralizing as a
quarterback this has never happened
before i don't think you have the guy
who has was sacked the most times this
season playing in the super bowl and the
guy who led the league in interceptions
is playing in the super bowl that
doesn't happen at that position no no
it's it's it's been a weird season it's
been an amazing season but when you
watch this bengals team the the achilles
heel of this team all year long has been
the offensive line joe burrows overcome
it
uh joe mixon's overcome it with just
stellar play and and being
a little bit quicker a little bit faster
you've seen joe changing protections of
the line of scrimmage we saw him do it
in the afc championship game
you know on the road in arrowhead
arrowhead stadium so he's got complete
grasp and control of what's going on
around him he can't overcome aaron
donald just overpowering the center and
bull rushing him and ending up in his
lap that is what's going this game's
going to come down to can they get the
ball out quick enough can they run some
screens can they run the ball against
aaron donald and can they not give up
six plus sacks against von miller on one
side and then aaron donald on the other
and plus you know you got jalen ramsey
saying hey bring it on
jamar chase
do you avoid do you avoid jaylen ramsey
you can't avoid jaylen ramsay because
you know at the end of the day we're
probably going to see jalen ramsey
trying to match up with with jamar with
with chase
they if you watch these last three games
they were moving chase all over the
field he was motioning he was in the
backfield he was in the slot he was out
wide he was on the three receiver side
the one i mean they did such a good job
trying not to let any individual
defender match up at some point you're
going to run into different situations
where you just can't continue to move
chase you've got to line them up and run
a play that's when you're going to see
ramsey on them but ramsay's built for
the megatron the 6'4
he's built for t higgins
he struggles against short quick fast
receivers and that's typical i mean most
big long cornerbacks struggle with the
short guys they do really well against
the big physical receivers so it's not a
great matchup for jalen ramsey there's a
quickness dynamic to chase there's a
speed dynamic to chase he's got to play
off him a little bit so i wouldn't avoid
him i like that match up from the bengal
standpoint of chase against ramsey okay
before we let you go the longest run of
carson palmer's career oh want to guess
that one damn yeah um i can give you a
hint it was with the cardinals and you
were 37 years old um wheels i had wheels
how many yards carson i'm gonna say
four
wait the longest run of your career six
16 yards 16 yeah 16 yards wow i was
probably at the end of a half when they
were playing pre-event defense
and i didn't want to risk throwing a
pick on a hail mary so i just ran and
got out of boundaries
i'll take it 16 is good yeah you were
josh allen before josh allen with that
running ability do you do a drive-by at
usc just go in and touch the heisman
there uh i'm actually driving by the
coliseum today we'll swing i got my son
with me so my son fletches with me so
we'll roll up to the sc campus and do a
quick tour but i i don't think you can
touch i think it's in a case oh
which by the way by the way oh no
it showed up
it got there
it made its way to me but the front
plaque was broken off of it oh geez
you didn't have it in the case in the
man cave
we put it in the case no no i'm talking
about like a clear case where nobody can
touch it um
i i don't know
what paulie i i thought fritzy was in
charge of the case
that was fritz i
delegated the back room yeah the back
room guy
can you get it fixed i fixed it oh god
how much was it done uh i i just had to
get some new screws for it we're all
good okay real good all right real good
i'll pay for the screws cool damn
i'm so glad you got that thing back i
love that you you loaned the heisman to
us but man when that was going back and
then we couldn't find it and then you
were going to the college football hall
of fame it wasn't worth it it was not
worth it
level select cbd
go use the promo code carson 40. uh we
want to thank level select all season
long great partner and uh you too uh
you've made us smarter every monday as
we uh recap football have a great
weekend with uh with your son and uh
thanks for joining us you as well thank
you thank you buddy we'll take a break
back after this
[Music]
okay so i want you let's say that one of
these guys was going to audition for a
quarterback role in the movie and then
you just judge
how they look they're going to drop back
so see the spin
i don't know yeah that's a good thing
that's a three out of ten right there
okay oh god
come on come on you can't oh god in the
middle okay what's the problem here
everything
that didn't
ball up good pocket movement
yeah uh
i don't know if i can say anything
positive about it that's okay
you look incredibly unathletic
in that movement with your elbows out
right i would touch the elbow right
that's a little bit better
you don't panic don't ever tap them
hold the ball do it
don't spin it in the pocket i think i
feel like the spin they always do that
right it's like this whenever they're
doing the like standing thing and it's
like now you know jimmy lipper from
whatever state yeah looks like they do
that right yeah that's not quite like
that but yeah that's what it feels like
i'm gonna audition to be um peyton
manning in the movie oh because his feet
let me see your forehead like this i've
got all right you've got a big forehead
okay that's right i gotta shave a little
bit but he his feet were always like
this
just like that
yeah and he always did this remember
they'd always
suddenly i feel better
you're in second place right now
you can take first place if you can
throw it it's a super quarterback thing
to do to throw the ball on the ground
and it bounces right back up to you yeah
but that's where you gotta be turned
into that
tom did that
okay you did one of these throw it like
you're normally throwing a football so
put your hands in the laces and it's got
to bounce bounce off the ground and come
right back up to you okay if this hits
you i apologize that's good
yeah
so you're like and you do a
well you gotta throw it
okay you've done this before okay you
just threw it on the ground
all right todd
next lefty let's go friends who are you
going to be okay oh wow all right all
right fair enough 28 baker bruce
triangle legs in omaha omaha
[Laughter]
oh look at that
i like that's the best one
all right that's great see and and
nobody did the dax we didn't do the dark
little hip thing no
and carson just said that do you throw
with your body your core your hips not
your arms yeah
and most people think if you got a good
arm exactly
and i always hate when they go well that
guy's got a cannon i don't care how
strong your arm is can you hit a target
exactly because there are a lot of guys
that you play with they're like damn
that guy can throw it really far yeah
you need to throw it short
especially when somebody's about to
smoke you right in the face
all right todd let's see you block it
[Music]
[Laughter]
i tried to hit you
thank you
thank you
thank you
good to see you pleasure talk soon
please talk soon
i agree